that's one of the best things you get to
do as a rabbi do a weapon which
everybody's there in love exactly
everybody there that a good time is
fantastic right exactly
it's food and dancing and and love it's
pretty good it's a pretty good trifecta
I believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and I want
to help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense today on the show I'm speaking
with Rabbi David Wolpe
who is a leading rabbi in America an
author speaker and was named one of the
most influential people in America by
Time magazine he was also named in the
most influential rabbi in America by
Newsweek we had a fascinating
conversation truly about how more alike
we are than different and you know I
placed the question on does religion
divide us or does it unite us it seems
like it divides it to me and we talked
about how we were similar and what we
really want and the fact that you know
what we all kind of want the same thing
so we built a bridge not a wall I hope
you liked the show today I'm excited
about this conversation because well
quite frankly I don't think we agree on
all exactly the same things but I think
that's a great conversation I do or if
it does mentioning having your culture
just Sadhguru but I want to start a
little bit more I wouldn't even call it
PC necessarily but but maybe what's led
you here today and that's media and that
you were like you know silenced in a in
a meeting with other rabbis in and by by
saying that the way that you can get the
religion out there is through media yeah
and why is it so hard to turn the ship
of institutions that have been around
for so long whether that's you know the
curriculum in school or you know the
status quo of what a normal relationship
looks
and how that goes into the world or the
practices and traditions of religion
right um you know why is it that we
can't why is it so hard to evolve those
things so I think that there are two
related reasons one is as you get older
you become fonder and fonder of the
things that you have in your youth and
you don't want to see them gone and so
like for me it's hard to see that
newspapers are disappearing because I
grew up with newspapers and I love
newspapers and I go out in the morning
and I get them even though it's a
ridiculous thing until I kill all these
trees paper right exactly when I could
just swipe it on my phone so that's one
is you have a personal nostalgic okay
and then the other is that institutions
are and religion and tradition is
suspicious of change because things
evolve very slowly and when you change
them you never know what you're losing
along the way things that have
unintended consequences
so when newspapers go digital we're
gonna lose certain things that we don't
even realize we're gonna lose like the
question of how you monetize digital
news and if you can't monetize it well
then how do you hire all those reporters
that are going to go to nowhere and
report on what's happening or all
someone just ctrl alt deleting all
information on the right we're changing
everything exactly we're changing it or
putting your face on my body or my body
going or my face on your body and saying
this is actually what the person looks
like and you have no idea if it's true
you can't do that with newspapers so
there are variations that people are
afraid of but in the end I agree with
the thrust of your question which is you
have to change you have to if you don't
change and you don't evolve you die and
so media is incredibly powerful and if
you have a message that you care about
and you don't use it to get that message
out you're just being foolish mm-hmm
what are some messages that you've felt
that are the most important that are you
know
the system breaking the mold and these
days actually the message that I've
tried to push a little bit is actually
this message it's the message that you
gave at the very beginning which is that
people who disagree can speak to each
other and not scream at each other
because on Twitter and on Facebook you
know that outrage is first of all its
pleasure people like to be outraged it's
fun to be outraged if you're indignant
about something you feel really good
about it and there's so much anger and
so much indignance that I feel as though
it is impossible to persuade someone
else of something because nobody gets
persuaded by having someone scream at
them and so I tried very hard to
constantly reiterate that message but
it's a tough one in our especially
politically these days you know I had a
very special experience of being able to
meet His Holiness the Dalai Lama and
that is really his message is to have
everyone be able to get along and have
there be tolerance for difference and
tolerance for you know I I have heard
that you know there are you know people
that practice other religions that come
to your synagogue and - so it's kind of
interesting because you came from a
background of being more of an atheist
really from what I understand right for
many years and then going into religion
specifically and diving all the way in
and believing much more in religion and
really not in spirituality so you know
here I'm looking at these messages on
two different religions and you having
this very inclusive demeanor to you so
but yet you're fixed on religion let me
tell you my problem with spirituality as
opposed to religion first of all I
wouldn't say I believe in religion and
not spirituality okay I think
spirituality is an essential part of
religion it's at the core my problem
with spirituality is alone when people
say I'm spiritual but not religious I
always want to ask them how much do you
give to charity
because religion is the organized
community's response to the promptings
of spirituality so I know in my
synagogue there are people who suffered
losses the community brings them meals
the community supports them the
community checks in with them the
community visits them because that's
what religion does but if I say I'm a
spiritual person what obligations do I
have as a result of being spiritual none
but if I say I'm a religious so-and-so a
religious so-and-so has to do the
following things and I'm always
suspicious of things that make us feel
good about ourselves but don't obligate
us to do something for someone else and
that's why I think it's dangerous to say
what's matters of spirituality and not
religion because that's saying what
matters is feeling and not action I
don't totally agree because I don't
think that I don't think that well so
here's how I would describe and again
I'm by no means in your position I've
had my own history and lineage of of
where I've gone in my life with religion
being in and out but to me spirituality
is saying I don't attach myself to one
religion spirituality is saying I
believe in a collective and a collective
idea or you know so it's not that I
don't believe I should give I absolutely
give to charity I was absent no I did
say that people say they they shouldn't
give I'm saying spirituality alone
doesn't contain those obligations and
and to say I didn't know that there was
really like an obligation to give even
if I was in religion like I was in
Judaism well Catholicism don't you pass
around the plate yes and okay your
spirit if your spiritual nobody's given
you a plate right that's true and that's
that that to me is the difference and it
almost like when people say I pick and
choose from different religions I want
to say to them almost you don't speak
lots of languages at once you speak a
spiritual rather religion is a language
it's Judaism as the language I speak to
God other people speak other languages
but the more you know your language and
the deeper you go into it the more you
can express I think I can be more
Universal the more Judaism I know so for
me you got to go deep not broad I'm sure
that in your sport you had to have a
deep and detailed knowledge that's what
made you excellent you couldn't say I
think I'll get in a car and drive around
you had to really know it so I think
when someone really knows their
tradition if they have deep roots that's
what gives you broad branches do you
believe in the idea that essentially all
religions are rooted in like the same
core values and so if you know enough
about one you essentially can know more
about others and can I say yes and no
sure okay I will I would say most
religion since I don't know all yea
share most values but they express them
differently and live them differently
and there are some real value and idea
differences in different religions that
are reflected in different societies so
that's why I don't try to judge other
religions because I don't live them and
when people ask me like why is Judaism
better than this or that I always tell
them that my job is to argue for
Judaism's excellence not at superiority
because I never was a Hindu so am I
going to say what's wrong with Hinduism
I don't know but I don't think that by
being Jewish I know what it is to be a
Hindu no I think they people do live
differently in different cultures and
societies but all are okay I well I
don't even want to say all are okay I
think all the major cultural traditions
have rich and beautiful things to bring
some of them over time turn in ways as
we know like nations do that are
dangerous or destructive so and have to
self-correct at some point I mean we
certainly know that in the history of
Western tradition I don't think any Jew
could say religions have always been
okay
when Jews have suffered so much
sometimes under gaemes of certain
religions to me with religion again with
my belief of spirituality versus
religion religion being just that your
your fixed with this one set of beliefs
spirituality is sort of all-encompassing
it feels like there's so much negativity
that's gone on in the world due to
religion I don't believe because they
divide it's like you are a man I am a
woman you are Jewish I am a Christian
you are black I am white like there's so
many things that divide and the more
things that we can do that unite feels
to me positive and that's I think that
here is where I really think Judaism has
something to say to the world because I
hear a lot of people make that argument
and I understand it on an intuitive
level but in the end I don't think it's
right and now the reason that I don't is
there exist and always will exist
differences between people all sorts of
differences nobody is a person in
general everybody grows up in a certain
place has a certain family as to on and
on so the question is not to make all
people the same the question is what one
Rabbi calls the dignity of difference
yes you your life situation and your
life path is very different from mine to
say you're basically the same as me is
in some ways to erase the real
differences mm-hmm instead what I should
say is you are different from me I have
so much I could learn from you because
you're different right from me right so
I like the idea of there being different
religions because I have a lot to learn
from other religions that's wonderful I
have I did just recently read something
about how and have a conversation about
how the differences are how you grow
without the differences how do you learn
how are you challenged and so then maybe
the real question is why the hell do we
fight so much about that right why do we
fight so much about it because I I mean
I think this is based in human nature
when you have
you're I mean all you have to do is go
to a playground when a new kid comes to
the playground what are the other kids
do do they say oh look a new child let's
let's bring him in and give him art no
they say get the new kid the idea I
think and and religion at its best
does this is you have to have something
that transcends all the differences and
the only thing I know that transcends
all the difference is is the idea that
we're created by one God I don't know
why else we share DNA so what we share
DNA with other creatures - mm-hmm
but if we're all have one parent I don't
want to say father
one parent mm-hmm then we're all related
in all children so then you're implying
and then it's not necessarily are you
implying that God is a man or a woman
are you just saying mom or dad I'm
saying God God is a man or a woman like
love as a man or a woman so God is
intangible God has no right I'd love to
hear your explanation what is God not
necessarily maybe even right but like I
explained okay to the extent the extent
first of all I assume I can't begin to
explain God because as I sometimes say
to the high school students when you
were two years old you had no idea what
it was to be a high school student and
the difference between us and God is
much greater than between a two-year-old
and a high school student so I have no
idea I can say what how I experience God
in the world which is different from
what God is and the way I experience God
in the world is that the world is a
unified creation that has in it enormous
potential for goodness for caring and
for love and also gives us the
possibility to be destructive and
hateful and the choice to be better so
God is in part the force that creates
the meaning of life which is to grow in
soul and to show that you can be better
and the better you are I think the
closer you grow towards whatever God is
so can God be a on energy I almost don't
want to say what God
is or could be because as soon as I put
any definition on God I'm sort of
limiting God and I and and my mind is
not does not begin to be spacious enough
to begin to understand what God could be
so I will say that God is what makes
those possibilities possible beyond that
I'm not sure that I could give an
omnipresent energy everywhere all the
time I would say that my understanding
of whatever God is is that that there is
no place that is absent of that whatever
what whatever God is yes so I'm the
present but I don't know if I would use
energy because there are things that are
energy and things that aren't and I'm
not yet comfortable or may never be
comfortable and what is everything is
energy is God the same as everything
that I'm not comfortable with either
that's why it's about that yeah
definitions are really tough definitions
are really difficult I prefer to stay
away from definitions of what God is and
stick closer to how you experience God
or what God does in this world okay
because it doesn't matter essentially no
I agree kind of doesn't matter what he
is unless you think maybe like I think
where I'm like if I can understand a
little bit better what then I can tap
into that better so for me in my
experience and my curiosity I would say
that to me God is the highest frequency
energy there is a I believe in this I
believe that everything has a frequency
and energy your water glass you do if
you took all the humans in the world and
condensed them down to dense matter
where an apple everybody in the world
so we're energy where we're at a
subatomic level there's a tiny tiny tiny
tiny little particle but otherwise just
moving around energy protons and you
know they're all that's just that's what
we are is energy so if I think about I
think about God I think about love and
love being such this high vibrational
like amazed
energy that is overwhelming and can take
take over your whole body I think that
if if God is love then then I I feel
like I've felt that love frequency
before glimpses of it here and there
because they think that there's higher
levels of it than just like residing in
a place of where you love someone there
are peaks to it and if you just keep
going from there then you get to God
energy and that's why I try and operate
in a way that I feel that I try and put
myself in a position whether I kind of
force it through writing down and
affirmations and things that are in a
positive direction but I think that the
more the higher my frequency is by the
more positivity I incorporate into my
life and having the right people around
me that also have that higher frequency
then I get closer to that than I am
living a better life because I believe
that the the fear and the hate and the
jealousy and the envy are low
vibrational and that's also where
disease resides disease of the body and
that you can't at a high very high
frequency those those problems also
don't exist so you've heard of like
stress will kill you right that's a low
frequency vibration so for me I think of
God as as an energy and it is my job if
I want the best life in this world that
I possibly can to do right which is be
kind which is give which is be generous
be selfless help and that gets me closer
and I I mean I think that that's a
beautiful way of thinking about God in
the world I I first I think we have I'm
more I have two sort of caveats one is
that I think a lot of disease is random
it doesn't have to do with the person
there are people who are wonderful
people pure Souls so on and they have a
genetic problem or some other problem
then they get ill so I'm not sure that
there's any frequency at which human
beings can operate where the normal
biological processes can't go wrong
that's one I want to say that because
I'm we're
you've got people right I've had cancer
a couple of times and I'm leery of
telling people who are sick that you're
sick because you could have actually
done something different and not been
sick the second thing that I would say
is I still believe that people are in
need of certain directions and ideas and
that that's what religion at its best
does because most ethical problems that
we have in this life are not a choice
between right and wrong they're a choice
between competing rights like when you
try to decide do I give my money to this
charity or that charity and you can't do
both it's not that one is right and one
is wrong but you have and but you have
to have a system for thinking about and
understanding which is better for you at
that time and at least in my experience
a religious system which is the
collective wisdom of thousands of years
can be very helpful in figuring out ways
to live that good life that you spoke
about
by doing what by giving you guidance
about the different ways that you could
that you can live that life because the
I'm not I'm not one of those people who
believes that my highest self is always
even if I can access it is always going
to make the best decision how do I think
flawed how does the tithing help that
how does you call it the same thing
right well yes actually Tyvek tithing
comes from the Hebrew Bible so yeah okay
so it presumably helps that if people
are using that tithing wisely I mean now
some churches do some churches don't
some synagogues do some synagogue stone
that's why I say the the flaw in the
system if it's a flaw is human nature
and human nature is intractable and
difficult and and I've never seen a
world I've never seen any world where
you don't have people being sometimes
angry and petty and small and all of
that and as you said we all find it in
ourselves right it's within you and then
you to fight to fix that
well within you to make it better I'm
not
you can never face that to me based on
especially how you've described
spirituality is about the self so how
can you leave that out I'm not leaving
it out but it's also about the community
it's about the self but it's also about
the community I think there is where
religion really hits you hard that's
nice to me part that I think so it
brings you in and you know I can say
that you know quite casually like I mean
I have my you know hi vibe tribe I mean
we cut you know you find your people so
I wouldn't say that just because I don't
practice specific practice a specific
religion means that I don't have my
group and I don't have my tribe of
people that that in my community of
people that are like-minded and that
we're doing good things or that we're
thinking a positive way and helping and
passing on you know positivity and
optimism Kota Lia Gris but let me just
give you an example of what I mean and I
think that you're absolutely right and
people do especially people who are who
care about these things find other
people and I don't mean to suggest for a
minute that people who are spiritual
don't do that you've made that clear on
there I have a friend who rebuilt an
orphanage in Haiti so I went down there
and I went to the general store which in
this case was like six shelves with
three things on it right
and and I met this guy and I said what
are you doing here and he said we're
building houses outside the city limits
and I said how long have you been here
he said 20 years I said what brought you
here said my son my I said how long has
your son been here 30 years why did you
come he said because our church told us
we should and I thought you will find
very few people there are some who will
spend decades doing something a
thankless task for people who are poor
in in basically abandoned parts of the
world who don't have some kind of
religious motivation many many more do
than don't some will there are doctors
without borders
but the biggest aid organization in the
United States is an evangelical
organization outside of Sea
called world vision most people don't
know about that but the motivator to do
good in good religion is really
incredibly powerful and widespread and
so I guess I feel as though religion
gets a very bad rap these days and
people don't sometimes account for how
much good it does in the world that
nobody sees hmm that's true I do do love
to see the positive side of it and so
when I think about religion I think
they're all good right but they do bad
things yes humans do bad things cuz
there's a human element right yes and
there's there's corruption there's
things that are inappropriate going on
there's you know there's greed there's
ulterior motives there's I mean there's
poor messages I think that's bad too
really the problem I remember when I
went to church I would be like if I
don't get a good message out of this
there's no point going I almost feel
blasphemous for going to just sit there
and think now I went to church like if I
don't get the message what's the point
and the problem is of course that
religion gives you power and power is
dangerous for people to have and I know
as a rabbi
I see like people take sometimes what I
say more seriously and if I want to
abuse that it's easy to abuse you know
as a celebrity people take what you say
more seriously and if you want to abuse
that it's easy to abuse and so there's a
constant temptation to power and that's
also something that religion write with
you know we had kind of touched on just
like you know the difficulties and you
know you know negative vibrations low
vibrations lacking positivity here and
there I feel like when you think about a
religious leader you think they must
just be on cloud nine right they must
just have a cake life and they're always
so positive and they're walking around
just levitating but that can't be true
and in fact it's nice right the opposite
so I would just love to hear of like you
know tell me your challenges while you
have the book so you also have life and
you're a human I would say the biggest
the biggest challenge apart from all the
other challenges that every other human
being has is that
you are vested with this responsibility
which means two things one you worry
about getting it wrong and two you know
that human need is much greater than
your capacity and so I know at any given
moment on any given day I could be
sitting there reading a book and I know
that there are probably 20 people I
could call that if I called it would
make their day or they would feel better
or they're sick and every moment that I
don't I feel like you know a burden
yes a burden yeah it's a I mean it's the
it's the flipside of a privilege sure
because do you call yeah or when you do
show up right we're really glad that you
did
usually but but but when you don't it's
you know a lot of people's lives I think
my the way I human Ellen I feel I feel
like when someone becomes famous I
always feel like people don't realize
what a tremendous burden that is because
when the 600th person comes up to you in
the restaurant and you are not nice
they're gonna feel not that they were
the six hundredth person and therefore
you weren't nice they're just gonna
carry I saw that Patrick woman and I
gotta tell you you know she's just not a
nice lady and that's what you get yeah
there is definitely that burden of
delivering on the expectation level and
I'm sure you I'm sure you feel that I
think a celebrity feels that when they
get famous but a religious leader feels
that of course you being a famous rabbi
but then also being a religious leader
and being this person that's supposed to
be so Zen and in the right space
although no because you're human and so
you know delivering on the expectation
level of someone is one of the harder
jobs because you have bad days and
you're going to disappoint and you know
you're not going to either the pedestal
is really high so that's I mean that's
but on the other hand you know you get
you get enormous benefits from doing
something among other things you get to
feel like even if you have a bad day you
didn't have a wasted day I never have a
day where you didn't do something that
was at least meaningful in the world at
least by your own
standards so right this kind of brings
me to a word a sort of a word to talk
about in general because what I heard
was that you have a lot of empathy and
you know that's why you are affected by
not being able to touch everyone that
you possibly can with every second of
your day and and having to preserve your
own energy just to operate in your life
so an empathy is a powerful word and
just in culture for us to have more of
so what can we do to cultivate more of
that yeah I mean I think that you that
that really is a big fault line in our
life is that people can't imagine people
unlike themselves very well and so I
know like the people I'm the the
clearest is right now people on the left
and people on the right speak about
people on the other side as though
they're just bad right not oh they have
they they see the world differently from
me they're just bad and and I I mean
among the I think that the most
important thing which is really hard
these days is to have acquaintances but
better friends outside of the circle
that you normally operate in you know I
mean I was lucky in that sense among
other things when I came to the
synagogue about half the synagogue were
Jews from Iran and people from Iran have
a totally different life experience from
anything that I had growing up in
Philadelphia and and it took a long time
before I started to understand how they
thought because they would tell me I
think this and I of course I started off
thinking no no no you're not correct you
don't understand this is the way the
world is not the way you think it is and
then I started to realize how provincial
and arrogant that was as though the
world was the way it is if you grew up
in Philadelphia we all need that
experience I mean people in Los Angeles
in New York and people who live in Des
Moines don't have the same experience
you know this very well you know this as
well as anyone so I mean even American
don't know each other very well and
that's too bad to me it's that fear
factor of something outside of your norm
that keeps people apart or skeptic or
even apprehensive to engage because they
judge without knowledge and in my
travels all over the world that I've
gone on which I got an app that you can
put in all the countries you've been to
and apparently it's only 12% of the
world so I have a long way to go but
I've found that everywhere I go people
are good yeah like there are bad eggs no
doubt right but I'm betting they're
probably dealing with something that's
inside of them that they need to adjust
and turn and fix so that they can go out
into the world and be the human that
they need that they really want to be -
but people are good everywhere you go
and I guess that's the tough thing about
you know religion or a sports fan or a
country you live in is they all feel
like they give me a reason to go I don't
know if I like you right you're Jewish
I'm not sure if we're gonna agree on
stuff I don't know that Oh Kenya oh
that's dangerous I don't know that I've
never been there so you know that's why
labels to me you know you know or even
like having 26 identifiable genders now
or whatever the number is like why do we
need one more reason to go you're
different
well I'm what reinforces what you said
is almost every country that I've
traveled to if you speak to the people
of that country they'll say people here
our people are so nice
everybody here is such a good person
yeah I will do take an enormous pride in
being good like Americans will say
Americans are good people right but you
know every other country will say that
too and that's because the general
experience I agree with you of most
people is that there are kind to each
other but but it's true you have to
overcome that natural distrust of
difference and one of the ways that you
do it I think is by having multiple
identities that is if all you are is an
American then of course other people in
other countries are not going to be you
but if you're also a mother
and you're also I don't know a soccer
fan and you're also seven other things
then there are other ways what's that
exactly find more ways to identify with
people who aren't like you because
you're not and nobody is one thing we're
all we're all a zillion that's the fun
part
exactly so there I witness that maybe
then maybe then you like media maybe
this is a marketing issue maybe religion
needs to be marketed in a different way
from being something that is rigid is
really rigid fixed and it's beliefs can
be cult-like maybe and it's activity you
know it's it's like practices and the
things that you do and may be inclusive
within but not without as much and you
know maybe the marketing of religion
needs to be rooted in like finding your
people right or something like that or
maybe in you know grow in this community
to be able to give back I don't know
what well I would say well I mean that's
what I'm hearing good a good example is
what you said the Dalai Lama who is very
much who he is it's not like he's
practicing twenty different religions at
once but he's a universal figure right
because he doesn't say you have to be
like me right to be good or kind or
whatever it is
this says be the religions are
everywhere he says wherever you live you
should practice that religion yep like
that's true so that's I mean yes he must
be a good market he does that I mean he
is God means those many books and you
know we sat with him for an hour and a
half and and a lot of the things that he
said were in the books oh yeah that's
right so he is his message is simple its
repetitive and repetition is also a help
in learning and he's a good-humoured
human being yeah laughs have you met him
then who sympathizes like he walked into
the room and there was a secure the
security there was about it there was
about ten of us and he walked into the
room and the
the security guy that we had with us he
he had we need security with the Dalai
Lama but he has he had a braid off of
his chin yet a goatee with a braid and
the first thing that his holiness did
when he walked in is he grabbed it and
he yanked on it and he didn't just like
touch this thing he was like wow and the
neck is going and I'm like wow this guy
so he's very playful and very childlike
and it was it's a really endearing
quality it's very relatable because I've
all been there right we've all been
childlike at that point in time so so I
also think that it that exactly that it
depends who your priest Minister rabbi
was because a lot of times what people
will think of the religion is who that
person standing up there is and that's
another both burden and privilege
because you could you can make it great
or you can create I think you're doing
an incredible job of being inclusive and
you know you know other religious
leaders whether there be Sadhguru or any
any Christian leaders that you are
inclusive and that the message isn't you
know fixed on the Jewish religion and
everyone doing those practicing those
practices but you know I'm getting maybe
it's you know find your community and
find get you let your let your let these
well-established communities so I would
say I want Jews to be more Jewish and I
want everyone else to be more of what
they are and I want people to be able to
both appreciate and reach across those
borders to being grateful that there is
this difference you know I mean I think
that that's look when I go to speak in a
church the only reason they invite me is
because I'm so Jewish they don't invite
me because I'm nothing they know me
because I'm something right and and when
I invite you know pastors to speak
because there's something so about me
because I was a girl racecar driver like
what is different something being
something is a good thing so tolerance
is what we need yeah I've made a lot
more empathy and tolerance I will sign
on to that yeah okay well what's our
purpose then I mean you know we've
talked a lot about religion itself but
as a human being you know what are we
here on this
planet to do and how are we going to
make the world a better place right so I
think you're here to grow in Seoul and
the way you do that is in part by
recognizing Iris Murdoch who is a Irish
writer English writer said that falling
in love is the very difficult
realization that someone else is real
because actually realizing that someone
else is fully real is not an easy thing
to do that their needs are as real as
yours
and I think that that's what we grow
towards that's a great way to describe
it I've never heard of describing like
that it's it's a brilliant being selfish
in your own place and going like oh they
are neat about these things that so I
think that that's what we're supposed to
grow towards but that's that's a
lifetime respect it's a lifetime it is
respect it's empathy it's understanding
it's a Lawrence and it's also that sort
of magic yes some somehow spark of love
for someone else that you can give them
the dignity of being themselves as
opposed to just being a projection of
you I wrote a book called holographic
University just said the word projection
so it got me thinking but we won't go
too far down that road so how I am very
passionate about like the the
fundamental of do good is is great and
all but let's actually fit what are some
some calls to action that we can use in
our really everyday life a practice a
discipline that we can use to to to make
that a reality for them for yourself
like from for instance for me I will
write in a journal and I will write you
know words of affirmation about positive
things that I'm either doing or that I
want and you know I try and really
manifest my life through thinking about
what I do want not what I don't want
right and so there's some more things
but that's a real simple one that I know
I mean I think gratitude is an
incredibly important feature of being a
good person and and the first thing
you're supposed to say actually is
as a Jew waking up in the morning is
modani laFonda which means I am grateful
to you because you open your eyes it's a
new day and I would say if the only sort
of modification I would make to the
routine is not only words of affirmation
about what I want but words of resolve
about what I will do for somebody else
because also because to be honest in do
it's amazing what you get out of doing
things for someone else it's just I mean
I have this with my daughter all the
time
I'll it'll be Saturday night not have to
go to a wedding and I'll say I can't
believe I have to get up off the couch
and I have to go put on a tuxedo or and
I could go do a wedding and she will
invariably say to me you say this all
the time and then you'll come back from
the wedding and I'll say how was it that
no there was because I love weddings by
the way do I go to any wedding I've
never been to Jewish I'd love it that's
one of the best things you get to do as
a rabbi do a wedding which everybody's
there in love exactly everybody throw
down a good time is fantastic right
exactly
it's food and dancing and and love it's
pretty good it's a pretty good trifecta
so I really do think and by the way are
the same thing is true when I go on a
hospital visit and the same thing is
true when I do a funeral I leave the
funeral not high like a wedding but
feeling if I did it well like that was
the most meaningful and satisfying thing
I could possibly have done with this day
yeah so I really think that if people
were more aware of how much they would
get out of those kinds of bacterias they
do the more yeah well I'm gonna take
that a step further to saying if to not
only maybe cuz I've actually done that I
mean it sounds like I can't you try
harder Danica but in Ruth I had heard
that before where you wake up and just
say you're grateful yeah just that's it
right and I did that a couple times so I
was like that felt good of course I
didn't do it any more but Jack but I
like okay so the fact that you didn't do
it anymore
yeah that's why I want to say that
religion is a discipline it's not just
to feel
that it's not just a feeling of
spiritual spiritual 'ti is also a
discipline I mean people who are really
deeply spiritual they all have spiritual
disciplines because the forcing yourself
to do something when you don't want to
is part of the getting there you know it
just is it's like practicing an
instrument yeah there's a great stir
about Isaac Stern who was a famous
violinist and after a concert a woman
came up to him and said you know I would
do anything to play the violin like you
and he said really would you practice 12
hours a day for 20 years because that's
what I did and that's I mean don't you
have people who came up to you and said
boy I wish I could do it yeah and you
think they have no idea how much hard
work went into doing what you did yeah
same thing same thing with the
spirituality or religion anything that
you practice you get better at you have
to want something enough you do
important to have goals right what a
good question what are your goals these
days abroad these days
I think that my goals are not so much to
do other than what I've been doing but
to do it better
and to do it in hopefully over time in a
broader platform exactly what you were
talking about because I feel as though
there are things that I've learned over
the course of my lifetime of the course
of being a rabbi that like we talked
about today that if you express them
people go oh that makes sense but they
don't but but they're generally not
known so how did you do that media I
would do your podcast I mean it's true
it's a beautiful platform it's a
emerging with these long I mean I've
done a bajillion interviews I'm sure
you've done a ton of interviews and the
norm is 5 to 7 minutes right it's like
if you get to commemorate if you get
through a commercial break and still get
to keep going that is a long interview
so I love this new expanded platform of
media in a digital way that creates the
you know just an opportunity to explain
some things and help people you know
really
gage and you know maybe some of it has
some repetition feel to it so instead of
hearing something for a hot second you
get to listen to it for an hour you know
and you're like wow and they were really
amazing and so and it's almost like it's
almost like travel I can travel you go
to these places you actually go there
and you spend time while they're good
it's like you listen to someone that's
if you know people that are Jewish
listen to this and they hear that I'm
not they hear that I'm not even really
what I would call religious and I go but
she seems good you know and people that
are my side say you seem good and so
these extended platforms are really
pretty amazing they are amazing because
you actually feel like you're getting
someone's message as opposed to the
curated three minutes that they prepared
beforehand and half cup right back up
here minutes so I agree it's really I
mean in that sense like I know there are
what they call content it's remarkable
how much you can you can take from the
world now if you want to I think that
you should start your own podcast and
that you should use it should be like
religion on religion and you guys you
should you should be talking to other
people that believe other things and
then it'll be transformative for people
to understand how you know like the old
Apple commercial I think it's like we're
more similar than we are we're more
alike than we are you know different I
know a very well-known podcast producer
who's been making exactly that case
that's true you should you totally
should I think that's a fantastic idea
because you know I being the leader that
you are it's in a you know you have you
have the ability to and the credibility
which is really an important thing to
deepen the message of inclusiveness and
deepen the message of community and
giving back and gratefulness and empathy
and all those things that we need more
of and as you talk to other people it
will become so much more obvious
it doesn't really matter what you
practice you just need to practice
something I think that that's as long as
you practice something that actually has
some substance and is real it can
enhance your life tremendously that's
why when people ask me that the goal of
life is and I say to grow in soul I
usually add something like and there are
infinite ways to do that yeah I mean you
can do it in all the ways that there are
to be human yeah it just depends yeah
whether you have a trajectory of growth
or you don't care yeah okay well would
you would you on this podcast promote
the absence of abuse and murder to
sentient beings by promoting veganism
absolutely would dramatic intro into I'd
say it for for more than one reason I
mean first of all I really think that
this is one of those things that a
hundred years from now just like we look
back on all sorts of things you can say
and I don't believe you a hundred years
how do we do anything exactly oh my god
I think the same thing I think there's
no way we're gonna murder murder this
adorable little pig or this baby cow and
call it a veal and eat it and steal its
milk and tear families apart and also
and also even if you think that that
won't happen there is no question in my
mind and I don't see how anybody could
really disagree with this but some will
that when you look back on how meat is
produced and how chicken is produced in
this I mean yeah we torture animals and
then we eat them so even if you thought
that eating them was okay
nobody can defend the way that they're
treated and the torture that they go
through you know I I am not all the way
there
but I thought years ago my first step
was well I would never kill an animal
but if it's dead already and on the
Shelf the next worst thing is that it
died for nothing
Hey okay that was the first step right
the second step was okay
I now realize that if I buy it I
contribute to the cycle right right I
don't think it tastes bad I have no
problem it's delicious that's not the
problem the problem is ethics and the
problem is you know I did a routine dive
on Instagram in to slaughter videos mmm
and that was shocking to watch I watched
this one video it was obviously not at a
you know mass production place which
would I don't know if it's worse or not
but it was a cow chained up to the wall
the very very short chain and the dad
had a saw and you couldn't really see
what happened but it alive was standing
there and slit its throat and then as it
fell he handed the saw to his child and
I'm like who can do this and how asleep
as a human being with empathy do you
have to be to do that yeah I mean
there's no question that it Corson's you
and it makes you less aware of the fact
that you're taking life which you are I
mean it's not human life but its life
and and also the other side of it is I
also think that it's better it's better
for human beings and it's better for the
world right and I there was a Yiddish
writer Isaac West have a singer who's a
vegetarian like 50 60 years ago when
nobody was and he was a won the Nobel
Prize and when he was at the Nobel Prize
thing someone asked him if he did it for
his health and he said no I do it for
the health of the chickens yeah and I
thought they're both true yeah it's I
think that there's no question that
that's I mean no it's clear already the
world is somewhat moving in that
direction but it's going to be a long
and difficult yeah well again and I
understand ultra it's it's an
institution
yeah right and just like all the rest of
them they're going to take a while to
change but I've seen such positive
things about you know the dairy you
wall is now half half plant-based now
right that of that's the other thing
science will help because they'll create
burgers from essentially do you eat like
a beyond burger I've had beyond burgers
and I've had impossible burgers yeah
yeah yeah I I like their five possible
tastes pretty legit yeah the beyond
burger came out with a new recipe and it
is good but it's a little bit more you
get a little bit more of the feeling of
plant base but they are good now I I
mean I have a standard of keeping your
little ingredients limited and they do
have a little bit more but if you really
look at because I wrote a book called
pretty intense and I it has its all
health and fitness and mind you there
are recipes in it that have to do with
me because I ate meat back then more
when I very rarely do now but but it it
was really like you know a difficult you
know it's it's it's just a difficult
thing for people to overcome it takes
time and I don't I I really step and I'm
not I'm not I'm not a judge II yeah no
I'm really not when I go out to dinner
with people if they order meat that's
fine with me I don't I don't tell them
you shouldn't do that I think there's
some things I could help one we should
we should limit the portion size and
restaurants well that's also true right
if we just limit it to like you're also
true now or eight or ten ounces it like
that that'd be the max that would be a
lot less dead animals and then at the
extreme you go while there if you still
did kill animals which they did back in
the day to survive what if we actually
had to go do it ourselves
yeah imagine how many less animals would
be dead then right I don't think that's
going to happen no I I'm with you on
that I'm with you on that core value and
I I think that it is like you said it's
the empathy seeping into everything yeah
I don't even kill bugs now what's what's
going on with me I guess I was
paddleboarding on a lake the other day
and there was a something on my leg and
I kind of flicked and it was a ladybug
so I made sure that ladybug wrote on
that paddle board all the way back into
Shore so that I could take it off the
paddle board and put it on a bush that
is a very high standard of creature care
give you another example this one's a
little bit more I know you're a rabbi
would bear with me here
as a as a spiritual guru a leader I was
in the shower it starts like that and
there was like a giant like I don't know
what they're called they have really
long legs and they fly I can't remember
what the name of them is but it was in
there and I was trying to get rid of it
and I actually did try and get it down
the down-low down the drain and that
sucker was a fighter so I picked it up
and I put it on the wall and like you
just stay right here and don't land on
me and I let that thing live because I
was like you're a fighter let me get you
off the wall off the of the of the
drowning surface again that is a pretty
high standard but it's the empathy
getting into everything yeah I think
that's an important thing well thank you
very much for sharing your perspectives
and you know I'd love to come hear you
speak at your synagogue again we would
love to have you sure it would be overly
an honor beneficial experience I go
thank you very much pleasure thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the subscribe button
you